they're hunting for Russians
the Ukrainian military Blitz is so fast
the Russians can't flee quickly enough
several have already been found hiding
in these abandoned and bombed buildings
the cleanup task force has its work cut
out for them in every dark room behind
every door and in every corner there's
potential Danger
and nowhere is safe right now they're
wary of a frightened Army which may have
left behind some deadly surprises the
ukrainians are going through all this
destruction and all these villages to
try and find Russians who've been left
behind but also any movie traps that
might have been left here
everyone is questioned often they've
hidden their documents they can be a
lifesaver when everyone is viewed with
suspicion but in the back Gardens and
Fields the scars and Terror of War
linger like ghastly statues
they're not sure it's detonated yet and
any wrong move could be catastrophic the
battle has moved on but the Terrors of
War remain
the Russian troops turfed residents out
of their homes to set up their bases
this was one of them but they seemed to
do little fighting
foreign
all the signs point to an
ill-disciplined group we found human
feces on this carpet floor and they fled
in a panic
more more bottles
looks like they left in a real hurry
still some Patties on the pan
and they apparently abandoned colleagues
who weren't quick enough
foreign
the Russians abandoned vehicles and so
much more
they left quickly but a lot of weapons
they stay here
about weapons
they left behind yes anti-tank weapon
and the level of Destruction is quite
staggering
[Music]
the bombardment left a trail of death
and fear especially for elderly
residents like Tatiana it's left every
living thing terrified
she and her neighbors buried her husband
outside their home as the shelling
continued around them part of her died
when she lost her soulmate
foreign
ER takes us to where her sister and
nephew died killed she says by Russian
soldiers she's looking for what remains
of their possessions
this is my nephew's shoe she says
and my sister's slipper
they were traveling in an ambulance her
nephew was badly hurt and Witnesses say
the Russians fired on them when they
failed to stop
that's all that's left of them she says
what happened next is unclear but her
relatives and the driver were buried
together where the Russians were camping
Witnesses say there was an explosion and
we found vehicle remnants nearby gallian
is consumed with sorrow
this is happening
the torment of what's happened here will
last long after the troops have left
Alex Crawford Sky News and yample East
Ukraine